this program contains copyrighted
material that may be used for purposes
such as criticism comment news reporting
teaching scholarship or research under
the provisions of section 107 of the
Copyright Act of
1976 All rights to the copyrighted
material used in this program are
reserved to their respective
[Music]
owners
hello and welcome to a wolf in sheep's
clothing I'm your host blessings win my
guest today is Davey John Garcia raised
am Miss spiritual UNC certainty his
quest became one of seeking truth
welcome Davey I'm so glad you made it
here yeah thank you for having me it's a
privilege to be here again you have such
an amazing testimony can we start with
telling our audience about your
spiritual upbringing sure so my my
upbringing is a little it's a little
unusual on on one side of my family it's
more more typical in the sense that
they're largely raised Catholic with a
lot of them converting to Evangelical
Christ Christianity in the late ' 80s
and early 90s and uh where I grew up in
San Antonio there was a very big U
Evangelical movement in the 9s was the
church the Cornerstone Church with
Pastor John haggy became very huge back
then and so one side of my family got
very much into that and the other side
of my family was very different and how
so that side of my family was very very
involved in the
occult and my my grandmother was a witch
and my family has a lot of memories of
her casting spells engaged in rituals
she was always cons she always believed
that there were evil spirits in the
house and that there were demons and she
would be engaged in things like black
candle magic to try and banish these
these spirits and uh my mother was
forced to participate in that and so
that was my grandmother and my
grandfather was no less strange he was a
33rd degree Freemason I see but he never
talked about it he was he was very
secretive were were there things that he
did that kind of tipped you off to his
leaning spiritual leaning or well he he
never liked to talk about spirituality
at all if if you try to talk about it
with him he would shut off the
conversation he didn't like to talk
about it but we knew we knew knew that
he was involved in something and then we
remember his his clothing that he would
wear MH he would often go out wearing a
a black apron with a skull and
crossbones on it and he had a this
Crimson Fez that he would wear with a
gold tassel and it had two cross swords
in and blazed in the middle and so we
remember that but I never really I never
really thought anything about that as as
a child and really we we didn't know how
involved he was into it until I after he
died actually so how did that occur for
you what was the process of discovery
well I didn't find out until reading his
obituary because they put he put it in
his obituary that um he was a 33rd
degree Freemason and they uh they even
included his titles which were Knight of
the Rose cross and uh Prince of the
royal secret now for you know members of
our audience who were unfamiliar with
what a a Freemasonry is could you give a
little detail about that sure it's um to
to most people it's it's considered as
just kind of a secular old boys club
where you know like-minded men who are
concerned with bettering themselves or
improving themselves like to come
together and engage in charitable Works
they'll usually do like fundraisers for
children's hospitals things like this so
that's kind of the outward veneer they
hang out they have like a Brotherhood
together where they have like a
camaraderie and they they go to each
other for for wisdom and mentorship and
advice but then there's a there's a
mystical element to it as well and they
they they accept you if you can believe
in any God they don't care what God you
believe in but you have to believe in
something you can't be an atheist really
and be a Freemason so so you mentioned
33rd degree so there's levels to this
yes membership yes and what what is that
significant of like like what is 33rd
degree now the now I know that my uh my
grandfather's title was uh night of the
Rose cross and Prince of the royal
secret and honestly I don't I don't know
what he had to do to obtain that rank
but it's a very high rank it's either at
the top or near the top okay and it it
kind of has a it it borrows from like
Ancient Ancient mystery School religions
where they kind of reveal
truth to you or their version of Truth
as you ascend up these rankings and they
have their own secretive process of
allowing you deeper into the fold where
if you're a lot I'm sure if people who
are involved in Freemasonry might be
listening to this and they might think
oh well that's that's nonsense we don't
do any of that stuff there's nothing
like that but at the lower levels it's
not it's not at lower levels They Don't
Really discuss things like this there
might be some vague spiritual inclin
ations or or words that get shared but
it's mostly like I said earlier where
it's you know fundraising charitable
Works camaraderie but the further you
ascend up the ranks the more spiritual
it gets okay the more you're you're take
you're taking Oaths and you're getting
more involved in the mysticism aspect of
it so how did all of this affect
you well spiritually
speaking well at the at the time my my
grandfather died when I was very young
and so I didn't really I didn't really
know um I didn't really know about any
of this but he would always just he
would say strange things and he would he
would say things that would later come
true and like he like he wouldn't really
think anything of it it would just be
some remark like like I know this is
going to happen and then it would always
happen and I just always knew my
grandfather had some it felt like a sick
sense to kind of know when something
important was was going to happen and it
uh the biggest part of that was it's
kind of morbid but he always told me
that he knew he would die before my eth
birthday and and he did and and so
happened he did so you also mentioned
your mother was into Witchcraft and how
did that manifest for you was there any
repercussions or well my my grandmother
was into Witchcraft and she I never I
never even knew her she's kind of a very
mysterious figure in my family she she
ran out on the family when my when even
my mom was still very young and so my
mother doesn't really remember a whole
lot from her just like these vague
memories of like Witchcraft and these
weird things always happening in the
house and she was a very uh emotionally
disturbed chaotic kind of a woman and
she was very into Witchcraft and I'm not
sure what flavor of Witchcraft that she
that she got got that from her even
where that that came from but her I
never met them but her sisters were also
involved in things like that and she one
day she just disappeared and then no one
ever saw her again she just she just
left where my mother my mother had
actually somehow she had a very loose
understanding of God and she was she
wasn't really into witchcraft really not
my mother but when we were by the time
my parents had me there was sort of a
there was sort of a thin veneer of
Christianity in the home and cuz my
mother was very like I don't know what
to believe right and then my father came
from a very vaguely you know quasi
Christian background where if you asked
him if they're a Christian they'd say
yes but if you actually like Catholicism
or well it it they were my father and
his family were raised Catholic but then
they became Protestants uh later on like
in the ' 80s and '90s they became
Protestants and if uh yeah if you ask
them if they're a Christian they'd say
yes but they you know if you ask them
about you know the Bible or any Doctrine
they they wouldn't really know they're
largely ignorant yeah yeah they would
they would say well you get into heaven
by being a good person or you know they
had very very vague understanding of
Christianity so it was just kind of a
thin veneer in the household but growing
up there was always strange happenings
in the house and in the home and it kind
of opened the door to this um
this occult energy and it's kind of what
opened the door for my later interest
into the occult as well so were there
apparitions what was happening in the
home yeah back then I was we were
convinced that our house was haunted and
it because it it really did feel very
much like a horror movie and it it it
actually it really kicked off after my
after my grandfather died and I I didn't
know why that was no one really
I don't know if we really made that a
connection with that but I remember that
was the case where we would
see we would see things that weren't
there you know we would we would see
apparitions or ghosts we didn't really
know what they were but we would
see beings in in the home and we would
always hear things being knocked over in
the middle of the night we would feel
like people tugging on our hair even
pushing us down the stairs and even
feeling like something crawling into bed
with us at night and me and my mother in
particular um we were particularly
sensitive to it my father did as well
not to the extent that me and my mother
did but all of us were were affected by
it were affected so did you find
yourself now being somewhat comfortable
with this awkward or uh Supernatural
kind of oppressive environment and if so
did you start to seek it out or try to
make sense of it h that's an interesting
question
at
first at first I was terrified of it you
know I think I think that the you know
any the natural human inclination is to
feel Terror when you're encountering you
know things of this nature and but at
the time I didn't I didn't know what it
was and you know I didn't have like a
Christian foundation with which to
explain these things or to find soless
from these things or anything like that
so I was kind of on my own and at the at
the time when these were things were
first happening I was terrified of them
but I became very curious as to what
these things actually are and so I
decided to I would ask my friends about
it and IID have conversations with my
friends and I had a couple friends that
uh that kind of they had stories maybe
if something happened to a family member
but I had a friend of mine in particular
named Paul who experienced very similar
things in his home and so we developed
kind of a friendship and like a kinship
over these like these strange these
strange um spiritual happenings in our
home we both shared that and I decided
to look further into it and I decided to
go online and just look it up and I
found out there was like whole
communities of people that were in like
these paranormal communities of people
who were sharing stories about what had
happened what they experienced you know
whether these stories are true or not
who knows but I remember reading these
stories be on these websites where
they'd share all these photographs of
you know supposed apparitions that they
had caught on camera and all these
things became really interesting to me I
developed like this Fascination by it
and I I would listen to you know these
different people's takes on what was
happening and you know some people had
very Pagan or you know occult uh new AG
takes on what it was that was happening
right and it it turned into a very
strong Fascination so you're starting to
feel validated by your own home
environment in the spiritual uh
environment that's going on there what
then did you start to do did you join
these communities how did you express
this this curiosity that you had yeah I
I would participate in these communities
online and I was I was really interested
in uh in trying to interact with these
beings and be I as time went on as I as
it became more normal as they were just
kind of infesting my home MH it I
developed a stronger interest in uh
wanting to actually try to contact them
and because I became less Afraid over
from since they were all around me all
the time it's overexposure to it I
suppose and all of this kind of all this
started happening around the time I was
uh going through puberty I was like 12
13 years old I was a teenager and at the
time you know as as a result of um maybe
the dark Forces in the home home and
puberty and other things going on I
became very depressed and morose and
very emotionally unstable and unhealthy
and all these things kind of came
together to turn into another interest
of mine which was dark Heavy Music and I
got very into dark Heavy Music and the
further I got into that music the that
music started to glorify things like
Witchcraft and the Occult and Satan ISM
and all these things and it it increased
that fascin it was like a perfect storm
cuz I got attracted to that music
because I was depressed and sad and then
it happened to be glorifying the very
thing I was also fascinated on by over
here and so these things kind of came
together and I I formed a whole
personality around this music and the
Paranormal and the Occult and uh that's
when I really got deep into it and I
wanted to seek these things out further
so as you became a practitioner did did
you start to develop special gifts
anything like that happened for you I
wouldn't I don't know if I would call I
wouldn't call it a gift but I was just
very I I began to become very unafraid
of these things and so I I got into
things like spell books and uh Ouija
boards and Tarot cards and all of this
occult paraphernalia and really it all
started out kind of as play you know
like I would I would learn about tarot
cards and I would just try it out and if
I got a reading that that ended up
foretelling something or gave me a
deeper insight into something it was
just it was very like oh wow it it
worked it's actually worked and you know
if I was using a Ouija board and then it
actually starts to move on its own it's
like oh wow like it's actually working
like there's there's something going on
here so some people would argue that
it's basically just a magnet right right
I've heard that before but describe to
us what is it like operating a Ouija
board well there's there's no magnets in
it it's really depending on what you're
using it's either a a piece of cardboard
which is you I remember you could find
these things at Toys R Us which is crazy
right I saw some at Target I was shocked
yeah yeah they have them at Barnes &
Noble and places like that still but the
older versions of these because they've
they've been mass-produced by big
companies for a long time but the older
ones are just a piece of wood and a
pointer which is also wood and the the
surface of the Ouija board it's very
glossy so it's easy to Glide the pointer
around and the Ouija board will have all
the letters of the alphabet and the
pointer will be uh spelling out words
and symbols to give you a a reading or a
meaning so the idea is that there's a
spirit that's using the board to
communicate with you and it's taking
control of the pointer and guiding it to
the different letters to spell out a
message to you and when you're using it
sometimes it doesn't work right for some
people doesn't doesn't work at all but
when it does work it's this it's kind of
like this electricity fills the room and
everyone gets excited like everyone's
like looking at are you moving it are
you moving it like there's like kind of
excitement and feeling in the air of
like what's H is this really happening
right now or is someone messing with us
but there's no magnets in it um I'm sure
some people will mess with people and
just take control over it but from my
experience it really did move of its own
accord cuz you want to very lightly
touch it to where you're not guiding it
you're just lightly placing your fingers
on it and it moves itself so it's
there's it's like an animated
automaticity to it yes nothing that you
are doing so you're you're certain that
there is a spiritual force behind it
that's propagating it yes and so once
you're exploring this does this start to
shift things that are happening in your
life it it does in the sense that I got
really into the Divination aspect the
communication with these beings and as I
as I did it really started to turn into
this whole worldview that I had because
as I would communic at first I thought
um I was maybe communicating with ghosts
or the spirits of maybe the dead or
things like that but these beings were
starting
to spell out messages to me and it was
mostly me and my friend Paul that would
that would do this we would do it
together and it would they it would
spell out messages to us and it was kind
of revealing to us that it wasn't it
wasn't like a dead the spirit of a dead
person but it was it was this like
transcend Transcendent being like a god
that was communicating with us through
this board and it kind of excited our
imagination that there's there's this
whole world that we know nothing about
but where we have the privilege of
having like a a glimpse into this secret
truth this secret spiritual underworld
that previously we had known nothing
about and that most people knew nothing
about and so it was very exciting it was
like a it was kind of the feeling of if
you've ever seen the movie The Matrix
it's kind of like seeing like we're
living in a matrix and kind of seeing
that there's this this real truth behind
that and as we communicated with these
beings it started leading us down that
path and it it it wildly shaped our
worldview so let's talk about how you
found your way out like how did that
come to
be well I was me me and my friend were
were heavily into it we were in a we
were in a a metal band at the time and
we it all those things all came together
the the music and the occultism really
went hand inand and
so as I continue to progress in these
systems and communicate with these
beings it was also um precipitated with
the rise of My Success as a musician and
so all these these things were coming
together so of my own accord I never
would have looked back from it and it
seemed like this was all leading
somewhere like somewhere that I was
meant to be and it really wasn't until
the the tragic death of my friend that
is this Paul Paul yeah and uh sorry to
hear that thank you he uh he ended up
committing suicide and it
was it was very shocking it was very
shocking um
he would sometimes he would he would
joke about it you know because we had a
very dark sense of humor but I never
actually thought that he would and it it
it never seemed clear to me that that he
was even considering doing something
like that but he did and the last thing
that he did before he died was he posted
a a clip of us performing
and uh he just said good night and that
was it and then he took his life and
that uh that that greatly affected me
that greatly affected me it's it's
almost like this connection that I had
you this Covenant this connection that I
had with this this dark spiritual force
was severed in that moment and I didn't
it's not that like I didn't throw away
my guitar my my spiritual per I didn't
throw it away or anything like that but
you felt disconnected in some kind of
way I just yeah I just didn't I just
didn't want to part participate in it
anymore it's uh it's like something
something infatuation kind of just broke
the
spell yeah yeah that that's that's
probably a good way of putting it's yeah
it's like a it's like a spell was broken
and I was uh yeah the the honeymoon
phase of that was over and I became a
lot less infatuated with it
and that's that's really what began my
um
my my walking away from that that
spiritual path so I'm a bit familiar
with your testimony and I know that you
started
researching um how to improve your sense
of literature writing let's talk about
how you found the
Bible right well the the Bible was
always interesting to me because you
know in in the
occultism that I was that I was
interested in um I had read all of like
some of these like occult texts and some
of these like apocryphal texts and uh
Gnostic Gospels like the apocryphon of
John the Gospel of Judas and those
things made the bible really interesting
to me in the sense that I didn't believe
the Bible was true but I believed that
the Bible and other religions all these
other spiritual systems had like an
exoteric knowledge that wasn't really
true but it was a Gateway for those who
were able to discern into a deeper a
deeper truth I see and these uh so the
Bible was interesting to me but I
thought it was like a superficial level
of knowledge and it it wasn't the truth
it was just a potential Gateway into the
truth but you could have done that
through the badita or whatever else so
it was just an interesting spiritual
book to me and it wasn't until later on
in my life where I developed all of
these different secular interests and
like you mentioned I was very into into
literature I always loved to read like I
loved literature especially classic
literature and I didn't want I didn't
wasn't really interested in going to
school and and studying it I just wanted
to be like a well- read person and so I
was just looking into what I could do to
study literature on my own to develop a
greater appreciation of these these
great books and so I started looking
into well how do I start how do I begin
a study of literature and I I learned
that literature it's very it's very
chronological it it all builds upon
itself so you can't fully understand
Shakespeare without understanding Dante
and you can't fully understand Dante
without understanding Homer you know
it's all chronological and you should
start with the very first book and which
book was that and the very first book
happens to be the Bible and What
affected that have when you started
researching and reading
it I as a gnostic right unbeliever I
never I never would have thought that I
never would have thought that the Bible
was the first book it but it's literally
the first book like like with two covers
and a binding and pages in the middle
like that was spiritually what effect
did it have on you spiritually well at
the time at the time I was just I
thought it was interesting I thought it
was curious
and cuz I didn't I didn't immediately
start reading the Bible when I learned
that I just kind of put a pin in it and
I thought that's interesting and the
Bible just kind of kept coming up in
other areas of my life as well and as it
did as the Bible just kind of kept
coming up and these other secular
interests I had I felt that something
was telling me like you should read the
Bible like it's it's time to read this
book and so I thought okay let's let's
see if there's something to this strange
old book after all and so I just started
flicking through it and I opened it up
to the the Gospel of John and the Gospel
of John it starts with that it's kind of
like a poem that start that starts off
the book where in the beginning was the
word and the Word was with God and the
Word was God the same was in the
beginning with God and all things were
made by him and without him was not
anything made that was made and in him
was life
and the life was the light of men and
the light shineth in darkness and the
Darkness comprehended it
not it starts off with that and I
remember reading that
and for some reason
it I didn't understand it like I didn't
intellectually understand it but
something like resonated in my heart and
told me that this is true praise God
like it just it pierced at the core of
something that felt real and true and
eternal even though I didn't really
understand it and I was surprised that
it made me feel that way I'd never read
something CU I had read all these you
know all these books all these dark
weird spiritual books and this was the
first time that I felt unequivocally
without anyone else telling me that
something about this is hinting at
actual truth so we're running out of
time this is a great place to stop why
don't you give our audience a sneak peak
of what we'll be talking about in The
Next Episode next time we'll be we'll be
exploring a little bit further of the
religion behind heavy metal music
intriguing thank you to our audience at
home for joining us know that God has
not left you defenseless against the
devil's deceptions he has given you his
love letter a human manual known as The
Holy Bible we can always test the spirit
of any practice against his word Isaiah
8:20 reminds us to the law and to the
testimony if they speak not according to
these words it is because there is no
light in them Christ Alone can set you
free free indeed from a wolf in sheep's
[Music]
clothing